I've always known that I was attracted
to guys to people of the same sex since
I was a little kid and I was raised
without any religion.
As a matter of fact,
I used to get Jesus and Santa Confused
when I was a child.
So I was raised without religion.
And um,
I,
I didn't go to school.
I mean,
I didn't go to high school.
I didn't go to junior high school for
any length of time.
So I,
um,
and then at a very early age,
I was plunged into this extraordinary,
uh,
living situation when I was a,
when my mother gave me to her,
her psychiatrist and his family to live.
So my sexual orientation was nothing I
ever questioned or struggled with or
thought about it just why I'm right
handed I'm right handed and it's just a
fact,
you know.
So being gay was exactly the same thing.
It was just a fact.
And it's always been like that for me in
my career all my life.
I never,
um,
I,
I've never,
um,
I've never been something I struggled
with.
You know,
I've,
I've been asked and I've actually been
criticized by some people in who have
misinterpreted when asked by the gay
press,
are you proud to be gay?
I have often reply.
I'm not proud because I haven't
accomplished anything.
If I were,
if I had been the child of Evangelical
Christian parents,
I'd be damn proud.
You know,
if I had worked for my identity,
I would be proud.
But,
you know,
I never did.
I do,
you know,
I'm proud of the,
um,
the game,
the lesbian people who came before me
and made it possible for me to take it
for granted,
you know,
but I myself haven't really,
um,
haven't struggled and overcome anything
and I'm not proud of being right handed.
Now at the same time what I would I
change and be straight if I could never,
never,
no interest would never do it,
never do it.
So I'm really happy,
you know this way,
but it's not like I accomplished
something.
I took her driver's test and passed.
I was just born knowing how to drive.